how's it going bros my famous back
welcome back to gary dark secrets
I'm soaked like it's ridiculous I don't
even [ __ ] know where he is
oh yeah I remember now he's ass I need
to go to the second floor but that I am
on this floor I don't I don't I have a
chipper what if I can use it for
something after living room key
Oh No
[Music]
but this is the after I know
thank tank what should i do pain tank
does something well what is that nice
sliding painting keep
[Music]
I heard the magazine
why don't you go
these tell me I'm out of here [ __ ] this
[ __ ]
he just definitely give up that little
[ __ ] it's a bit like that guy I call
him my bed I don't care don't care see
you watch a character yeah what a gap in
our cap
what the hell come on is he everywhere
now
- Jesus he's not Jesus
it doesn't tighter but I know it Stanny
a third living room
or find another route well what the [ __ ]
all right we're just gonna have to do it
I'm gonna throw mr. Sherr to distract
him and then dad it that is all I got
right now
God bishop all right did it work
I don't think it boy all right plan
[ __ ] million just caught my eyes and
run
open thank you thank you well luckily
it's a [ __ ] so that helps are we back
here
really it's really
okay no we broke through Oh Locker oh he
doesn't know how many eh
come on I can't tell pass it like that
I just can't
[Applause]
ah
luckily in return
[Applause]
this door of my life and I just I just
kill myself I'm serious
how what are you doing in here
[Applause]
but if I spiral [ __ ] you back your
barrel got your barrels of you they're
all [ __ ] pair of you better [ __ ]
better for you better for the better for
the better for the better for Papa
barometer cut back there
it's still after me what do you want
from me I lit the candle for you this is
ridiculous
you're ridiculous
okay you're not ridiculous
all right I think we'd get actually
yeah it's got a bit it's gotta be it if
this isn't it I'll kill someone why
whatever you want me to go oh whoa
what's going on here oh wow it's a shark
do you like the moonlight baby do you
like it it's beautiful mr. shirt I'll
let you sleep [ __ ] why I am never been
in here before
I just Pat bird loves his room leg I
don't know man but I don't know you that
that's why I ask you cheese okay okay I
have a chipper and a hammer
oh thank you whoa what's going on what
was that
I'm sick with that I'm done I'm done I'm
gonna share now no I'm not gonna do oh
let me show ya my bad
don't
that's why I get back
yeah oh man don't let go I got its back
huh - please please please how much yeah
I'm a [ __ ] champion
I don't know if [ __ ] is it going fine
I'm a [ __ ] chef how did wagon pick
don't ask questions
stand up
he never [ __ ] disappears I hate you
you hear that I hate
I think after
[ __ ] you looking at me
go on
[Music]
haleh chef all right the combination
does not work
excuse me sometimes I wonder what this
game wants for me the thing is now
there's two of them
that's the best part that's my favorite
part
another [ __ ] it right there sayonara bye
guys oh my god
ah ah
I dodge him like a freaking ninja and
this happens and I panic god damn it
piece of [ __ ]
I'm sick of the shadow I'm sorry
yeah that's right you take whatever to
note
I'm staring into your soul right now
alright let's just focus on the past I
mean forget the past and forget about
the few what focus on five forget the
past
focus on the future all right I wrote
that word
it's copywriting what it has going on oh
and my [ __ ] why did he turn in my ass
out of my but it's really Thor no I
better I better what where's my
flashlight ah [ __ ]
no no no no okay be somewhere on there
does it have to be so damn dark I don't
know which way we're supposed to go I
guess we came from Oh
all right because it's impossible you
just [ __ ] pick that up [ __ ] [ __ ]
character I'm sorry all right let's go
to the lab are back what
let's not go to the laboratory
you [ __ ] barrels I see you that
working with the shovels and [ __ ]
I knew his shovels wasn't trustworthy Oh
babies now what are you someone coming
or what
why did you know I'm sorry you son of a
[ __ ] you mean are you pointed at you I
don't even want to look at you all stars
that's red sock doc I like a window he's
out there is me wearing its high heels
as you sure I think there is a key by
the fight no something's coming out of
my own here madam Adam give me a [ __ ]
break
all right I'm in this room now flipping
woodson [ __ ] you know what that's it
hello Eric I don't care okay alright I
got very ready enjoy subscribe to come
abroad today and I'll see you next
episode of why I'm a Salesman
[Music]
you're angry how do I know if he's stuck
all right
hahaha his butt